corona in johann herrschte zwei monate
totenstille
ein jahr später das leben pulsiert
wieder der preis katalog downs
massentests china will 0 infektionen
wir treffen familie ja sie haben angst
vor der zweiten welle
wir machen uns immer noch sorgen wenn
unser kind oder wir müssten
heldengeschichten eine ausstellung
feiert chinas triumph die staatsmacht
unterdrückt gnadenlos kritik
[Musik]
opfer geschichten sein vater starb an
corona er klagt gegen das vertuschen
wird zum staatsfeind mich machen die
ständigen besucher der polizei wütend
nur weil ich will dass der staat
verantwortung übernimmt
propaganda china als pandemie gewinner
das virus und die bürgerrechte werden
bekämpft
sie berichtet in den sozialen medien
über die unmenschlichkeit dafür muss sie
ins gefängnis
ich denke es ist unmöglich für mich
aufzuhören weil das verbrechen in diesem
land nie aufgehört hat
[Musik]
elf millionen menschen leben in buch und
jeder hat seine eigene lockdown
geschichte
manche sind heldenhaft manche traurig
manche zeigen mutige menschen
und manche einen brutalen start die
geschichten von wo hans bürgern erzählen
viel über chinas zerrissene seele
während des lockouts hatten wir kontakt
mit young zum seine familie geht es gut
die erinnerungen wühlen sie immer noch
auf von einer stunde auf die nächste kam
ihr leben zum erliegen
[Musik]
wir waren gar nicht auf die quarantäne
vorbereitet es kam alles so plötzlich
wenn ich so einen virus ausbruch noch
einmal erleben muss weiß ich besser was
zu tun ist
er steht wieder am fenster wie vor einem
jahr damals filmte er aus seiner wohnung
die geisterstadt
[Musik]
es waren die ersten blicke auf das zu
gesperrte wo hahn
die ganze welt schaut auf diese stadt
versuchte zu begreifen
hier auf dem fischmarkt infizierten sich
zahlreiche menschen
[Musik]
die regierung versuchte den ausbruch zu
vertuschen
ließ die bürger mit der gefahr allein
ein freund hatte mir damals anfang
dezember schon eine nachricht geschickt
dass in wohin eine unbekannte
lungenentzündung ausgebrochen ist er
warnte mich mit dem kind nach draußen
spielen zu gehen
damals habe ich mich nur gegen einen
grippevirus geschützt heute versperren
hohe stellwände mit berg motiven und
palmen davor den blick auf den
fischmarkt
der ort ist zu einem weltweiten symbol
geworden
er setzt das land auf die anklagebank
[Musik]
bonn legte mit beginn des lockouts ein
videotagebuch an
er filmte seinen alltag das machte ihn
zum social media sda
[Musik]
hier wird er von seiner frau
desinfiziert bevor er die wohnung
betritt seine angst sich anzustecken
ging um die welt
dieses video wurde am meisten angeschaut
mehr als 30 millionen klicks allein in
einer nacht habe ich 130 tausend
follower bekommen
seine videos zensierte staat nicht denn
sie zeigen einen chinesen der die
kontrollen befolgt und täglich für seine
familie sorgt ich finde china hat das
wirklich gut gemacht egal welche
maßnahmen die kommunistische partei
beschließt wir vertrauen ihr du bist so
ist glaube ich
du denkst wirklich nicht nach ist noch
nicht sehr glücklich dass du in china
lebt müssen die maßnahmen besser
erklären damit das volk mitmachen kann
es ist nicht in ordnung dass die
befehlen und wir sollen einfach folgen
das ende des lok downs feiert china mit
glänzenden fassaden die regierung
erklärt johann zur heldenstadt geehrt
werden die lebenden für die opfer des
vertuschens gibt es keinen platz
shanghai hat immer an sein land und an
die partei geglaubt
unfreiwillig ist er zum ankläger
geworden
wir treffen ihn in einen park inn wo an
[Musik]
mir geht es nicht gut
lasst uns mal hier lang laufen denn wir
sind hier nicht weit weg von dem ort an
dem ich mit meinem vater spazieren ging
letzten sommer ging ich hier noch mit
ihm gewesen sein vorwurf die partei
verschwieg den ausbruch des virus
deshalb starb sein vater an corona ich
unterstütze er die partie und ich liebe
männer aber nicht jedes mitglied der
partei ist ehrlich die macht verführt
einige korrupt zu werden oder die
gesetze zu brechen
die regierung von johann verschwieg den
ausbruch ihr verhalten verletzt mich ich
kann dazu nicht schweigen
andere können das vielleicht mache ich
aber nicht
wir treffen shanghai in einem hotel er
erzählt uns von den vermeidbaren tod
seines vaters
shanghais geschichte will chinas
regierung nicht hören er zeigt uns die
aufnahmen aus dem krankenhaus wenn man
ihm zuhört bekommt der mythos vom corona
triumph resse dreimal hat ihn bereits
die polizei verhört er nimmt das alles
mit dem handy auf überwachen und
bedrohlich auf der polizeistation
erklärten sie ihm er solle nicht mit
ausländischen medien sprechen wir seien
doch alle chinesen sagten sie dieser
satz machte mich wütend als sie
informationen verschwiegen haben legten
sie auch keinen wert darauf dass wir
alle chinesen sind jetzt wo ich die
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft ziehen
will
da ist es ihnen auf einmal wichtig dass
wir ja alle chinesen sind am 16 januar
2020 vor shanghai mit seinem 70 jährigen
vater nach wo hand zu einer oberschenkel
operation reine routine
das zu diesem zeitpunkt schon das corona
virus in der stadt wütete wusste er
nicht
er dokumentierte den körperlichen
verfall
er sammelte beweise gegen die die von
dem virus wussten aber nichts sagten am
ersten februar starb sein vater als die
vier männer meinen vater auf einer bahre
wegtrugen folgte ich ihn sie die tür vom
leichenwagen öffneten sah ich dass
bereits ein gelber leichensack darin lag
entscheidet sich die stadtregierung von
johann zur verantwortung zu ziehen
er zeigt uns seine anklageschrift sie
wurde bisher von den gerichten gar nicht
erst zugelassen
aus formalen gründen
andere klagen nicht aus angst vor dem
start
wenn man die verantwortlichen zur
rechenschaft ziehen will drohen
konsequenzen
zum beispiel am arbeitsplatz oder die
kinder dürfen nicht auf die schule ihrer
wahl daher schweigen fast alle obwohl
sie hats in sich tragen weil ihre eltern
an corona gestorben
die gedanken an seinen vater lassen ihn
nicht los
eine entschuldigung der verantwortlichen
würde ihm schon reichen aber die wollen
ihn nur zum schweigen bringen
meine wut wird immer stark
sie wächst mit der zeit wohl schon so
lange her ist bevor mein vater ins koma
fiel
hat ihr zu mir einen satz gesagt den ich
niemals
nein zum papa möchte nicht sterben
flea die ärzte an sie sollen mich
bittere ich da von diesen satz nicht
denken sonst werde ich immer sehr
traurig shanghais schicksal ist das von
vielen zehntausenden die tränen der
korona opfer sind aber nicht erwünscht
ingo hahn gibt es viele menschen wie
shanghai auch sie haben angehörige
verloren auch sie sind wütend
aber sie machen einfach weiter
es gibt eine lust zu feiern wie überall
auf der welt und viele sind auch
glücklich dass sie die 76 tage locker
und überlebt und durchgehalten haben
hier in der konzerthalle erinnern nur
noch die masken an das virus
in einer gigantischen ausstellung in
johann zelebriert china seinen corona
triumph
der besuch ist ein patriotische pflicht
ärzte krankenpfleger und soldaten werden
hier geehrt
sie kam nach wochen um die stadt zu
retten und natürlich onkel schwebt über
allem
fast die hälfte der ausstellung
beschäftigt sich nur mit seiner
bedeutung im kampf gegen korona das
virus hat den präsidenten noch mächtiger
gemacht aber im land herrscht weiter die
angst vor einer zweiten welle
die spürt jeder der in china lebt das
virus ist immer noch allgegenwärtig
das verunsichert auch jan zungen und
seine frage wir haben angst dass das
corona virus wieder zurückkommt das
macht mir große sorgen
auch wenn ich finde dass man relativ
sicher ist aber wenn du kleine kinder
hast bist du beunruhigt sonst wären wir
wohl entspannter eine zweite welle
könnte sich das land auch wirtschaftlich
nicht leisten dongguan im süden chinas
ist das herz der textilindustrie und der
elektronikproduktion
sie nennen die region auf den berg bank
der welt hier bekommt man ein gespür
dafür wie es china wirtschaftlich
wirklich geht es gibt gewinner der krise
so wie ihn
[Musik]
in unserer branche hat sich der gewinn
verdoppelt mit unseren
elektronikprodukten konnten wir unsere
geschäfte durch corona verdoppeln
die nachfrage nach lautsprechern kameras
und elektrogeräten steigt seit die welt
in quarantäne ist china profitiert davon
günstiger arbeitskräfte kaum
arbeitsschutz auflagen keine
gewerkschaften und doch spürt auch chen
xue chen die weltweite krise durch
lieferengpässe
[Musik]
china exportiert mehr als es importiert
es gibt zu wenig container die preise
für seecontainer schießen in die höhe
und das ist ein harter schlag für uns
ein käufer vor der pandemie kostete ein
container nach europa circa 1.000 us
dollar
und jetzt kostet er 10.000 usd china hat
die pandemie bisher wirtschaftlich im
vergleich zu europa und den usa gut
überstanden
die wirtschaft wächst wenig zwar aber
sie wächst
gleichzeitig gibt es verlierer die die
pandemie wirtschaftlich nicht überlebt
haben sie bekommen kaum aufträge aus dem
ausland bleiben auf ihrer ware sitzen
es sind die vielen millionen tagelöhner
die schwachen die als erste spüren wenn
das land probleme hat corona hat die
textilbranche schwer getroffen
[Musik]
in den ersten sechs monaten hatte ich
noch ein paar altaufträge seit mitte des
jahres gibt es keine neuen mehr
seitdem haben wir nichts mehr zu tun
als wir im letzten jahr im mai das große
textil zentrum der stadt besuchten
herrschte erschreckende lehre von ihr
beliefert china die welt mit billigen
klamotten
sechs monate später scheint die halle
wieder gefüllt mit leben und
verkaufsständen
[Musik]
bei näherer betrachtung aber wird klar
das geschäft läuft nicht so
wie es sein sollte wir betreiben
hauptsächlich großhandel der bestellt
zurzeit weniger ware kein mann kann das
verkaufen anfangen dieses jahres wird
wieder eine elf millionen metropole
komplett abgesperrt
[Musik]
erinnerungen an woran werden wach
doch diesmal waren nur zwanzig
infizierte der auslöser
die angst vor der zweiten welle vor dem
mutierten virus lässt china fast panisch
reagieren
in chittagong wird das kriegsrecht
verhängt der ausbruch steht dafür dass
das kontrollsystem immer noch lücken hat
das macht chinas machthaber nervös
innerhalb von nur drei tagen werden alle
elf millionen bürger getestet
über lautsprecher in den vororten kommen
die anweisungen vor allem in der
hauptstadt peking wird ständig streng
kontrolliert das machtzentrum muss virus
frei bleiben massentests und überwachte
quarantäne für hunderttausende sobald
ein infizierter auftaucht sind hier
normalität
[Musik]
china diskutiert nicht über abflachen
der infektions kurven und instanzen
china will nicht das virus eindämmen für
peking gibt es nur ein ziel 0
infektionen
wir müssen solidarisch sein
nicht nur in der aktuellen krise sondern
auch bei der gestaltung einer besseren
zukunft präsident viel ist seine
himmlischen sätze von seiner propaganda
abteilung mit bildern garnieren
[Musik]
er lässt die geschichte von goran
schreiben in lichtgeschwindigkeit werden
nicht nur dokumentationen über die tage
des lok downs produziert sondern auch
eine 10 teilige fernsehserie mit allen
chinesischen stars es ist ein rührstück
in dem auch verzweiflung und leid platz
haben
am ende gewinnt china den volkskrieg
gegen das virus unter der führung der
partei
jeder der eine andere geschichte
erzählen will hat ein problem
zum beispiel menschen wie georgia die
sich trotz des lok downs nach wo
handwerker
mit ihrem handy filmte sie den täglichen
überlebenskampf sie widersetze sich der
parteilinie zeigte die realität dieser
stadt das chaos überforderten behörden
die unfähigkeit fehler einzugestehen
deshalb sitzt sie im gefängnis
was hier passiert ist eine tragödie für
das land
wir treffen ihren anwalt john kirkland
kontakt zur außenwelt er spricht für sie
weil der staat sie zum schweigen brachte
als ich sie wieder so erfuhr ich dass
sie in einen hungerstreik getreten ist
die gefängniswärter haben ihr eine
magensonde eingeführt und sie wird von
mitgefangenen zwangsweise gefüttert
zieht sich die röhre immer wieder heraus
und geben die haft zu protestieren
ihre hände werden deshalb jeden tag 24
stunden lang an die taille gebunden
um auf die toilette zu gehen oder ein
bad zu nehmen oder ihr gesicht zu
waschen
braucht sie jemanden der ihr hilft wenn
sie bringen sie nicht los wir begleiten
jumper auf dem weg zum gericht
seiner mandantin droht eine haftstrafe
der fall sorgt für aufsehen
die internationale presse begleitet ihn
die heimische polizei will diese bilder
verhindern
ein jahr corona china nicht freier
gemacht im gegenteil das virus gibt dem
staat einen vorwand für mehr kontrolle
und unterdrückung
die regierung kann die wahrheit nicht
ertragen denn sie will nicht der wird
die zahl der gestorbenen reden
sie will nicht die gesellschaft und die
bürger über den verlauf der katastrophe
aufklären die regierung und ihre beamten
haben angst zur verantwortung gezogen zu
werden
das gericht fällt ein hartes urteil vier
jahre haft wegen unruhestiftung china
nennt sich selbst einen rechtsstaat
[Musik]
aber die verteidiger müssen wir in einer
kleinen gasse treffen neben wimmelt sie
haben angst vor der staatsmacht
das urteil sei eine warnung entweder
lässt die regierung die blogger einfach
verschwinden
und man weiß nicht ob sie noch leben
oder sie werden die meinung im ausland
ist ihnen egal
mit dem urteil verbinden sie eine
nachricht klopfe an um den tiger zu
warnen oder töte einen um 100
[Musik]
nur wenige bürger journalisten wagten es
das vertuschen der behörden in johann
anzuprangern
sie sind weggesperrt oder verschwunden
wie das virus versuchen chinas
machthaber auch die wahrheit zu
kontrollieren viele probleme wurden
nicht gelöst einige menschen sind
möglicherweise aus diesem grund
verstorben oder ihre krankheiten wurden
nicht rechtzeitig behandelt vor so
beunruhigenden überlegungen sollen
chinas bürger geschützt werden
janson und seine familie haben sich dazu
so ihre gedanken gemacht
es sind bürger journalisten festgenommen
wurden haben sie davon gehört
es hat bestimmt solche leute gegeben
im chinesischen netzwerk gibt es
allerdings zensuren aber auch wenn wir
solche videos sehen können was bringt
uns das doch nur mehr panik
egal ob sie die wahrheit gefilmt haben
oder nicht sie beunruhigen doch nur die
bevölkerung damit und bringen so die
ordnung durcheinander
wenn ich dort gewesen wäre hätte ich
auch die wahrheit gefilmt damit es auch
andere sehen können
aber die regierung wie die herzen der
bevölkerung beruhigen
[Musik]
dazu gehört auch die impf offensiver
ende dezember wird das wachsen des
chinesischen unternehmens sinopharm im
land zugelassen
die chinesen hüten ihre
forschungsergebnisse wie ein
staatsgeheimnis
deswegen ist es schwer zu sagen wie gut
oder schlecht der impfstoff ist
wochenlang haben wir nach einer
drehgenehmigung angefragt im januar ist
es dann soweit
diesmal hat das informationsbüro
ausdrücklich zu einer pr-tour in peking
eingeladen
im eingangsbereich begrüßt uns eine
gigantische videowand
china will mit seiner elf politik
beeindrucken
nur wer zwischen 1859 jahre alt ist wird
geimpft
der schutz soll erstmal für die
arbeitende bevölkerung gelten
wer hier sitzt ist in seinem alltag
erhöhte ansteckungsgefahr ausgesetzt
ärzte pfleger taxifahrer sind zuerst
dran
insgesamt in china langsamer als europa
zwei jahre wird es wohl dauern bis 1,4
milliarden menschen durch geimpft sind
wenn ich die impfung schütze ich nicht
nur mich sondern auch meine mitmenschen
diese pr tor der chinesen soll zweifel
im ausland am impfstoff beseitigt
einige internationale experten stellen
die angegebene wirksamkeit von mehr als
70 prozent in frage
chinesische ärzte dagegen keine bedenken
wir haben bisher keine ernsthaften
nebenwirkungen festgestellt
manche haben schmerzen rötungen oder
erhöhte temperatur ende januar ist
präsident zum weltwirtschaftsforum in
davos zugeschaltet es ist die wohl
wichtigste bühne für die mächtigen die
in diesem pandemie mit einer
ungewöhnlichen neuen währung verhandeln
impfstoffe chinas gegner die usa fallen
bisher als krisenmanager aus das nutzt
hier und will weltweit den ton angeben
der chinesische impfstoff soll allen
ländern zur verfügung stehen die china
nicht kritisieren
[Musik]
jetzt hat china mehr als 150 länder und
13 internationale organisationen im
kampf gegen korona unterstützt
medienwirksam lassen sich mehrere
regierungschefs mit dem chinesischen
impfstoff behandeln die lieferungen an
die welt werden wie staatsbesuche
zelebriert pekings machthaber brauchen
diese bilder für ihre internationale
charmeoffensive nicht das virus kam aus
china
sondern der rettende impfstoff das
wollen sie als botschaft die sich
weltweit in den köpfen festsetzen solle
wir sind eines der länder die keine
angst haben mit einer guten beziehung zu
china zu prahlen
dagegen herrscht in den chinesischen
sozialen medien und staatlichen
fernsehsendern oftmals purer
nationalismus aggressive propaganda
gegen den westlichen impfstoff von
baxter
eine frau zuckt vor laufender kamera
nachdem sie den impfstoff bekommen hat
eine geimpfte krankenschwester bricht
bei einer pressekonferenz zusammen
ein bericht handelt von 23 menschen in
norwegen die nach ihrer impfung
gestorben sein
die norwegischen behörden sahen sich
veranlasst zu reagieren und richtig zu
stellen
viele der patienten in den pflegeheimen
befinden sich in der letzten phase ihres
lebens
bislang gibt es keine belege dass die
korona impfung zu einer höheren
sterblichkeit geführt hat ein jahr
corona präsident staudt seine macht aus
das virus scheint unter kontrolle aber
die bürger sind unfreie
peking feiert seinen niedrigen
infektionszahlen als triumph über den
westen
aber chinas kampf gegen korona ist
komplexer als pekings helden geschichten
die sie der welt erzählen wollen der
blick zu den menschen nach hahn zeigt
alle facetten chinas und die risse des
systems familie young hat für viele
chinesen den lockdown erlebt und
erlitten
china hat im vergleich zum rest der welt
die krise relativ gut gemeistert
dann hat sich gegen die regel nicht
widersetzt deshalb scheint alles gut
gelaufen zu sein
[Musik]
shanghai spricht für die opfer er kämpft
gegen das vergessen der toten
[Musik]
sie alle hatten ihre familien ihre
eltern ihre frauen ihre liebsten ihre
geschichten kann man nicht einfach so
auslöst langsam sitzt im gefängnis weil
sie kritisierte der staat hat menschen
wie sie und tod gemacht weil es ein
verbrechen ist über die eigene wahrheit
zu berichten dann muss ich weitermachen
[Musik]
rückkehr nach vorhang ein jahr corona
zeigt eine regierung die dem sieg über
das virus alles unterordnet und es zeigt
ein land zwischen triumph und traum
[Musik]